you can do this
[Music]
brothers this morning the old hbo series
and uh i was reminded of what's quite
possibly one of the craziest stunts that
people have ever done they had a tank
well let me preface this actually we had
a tank in rush and we needed to do a
scene where the tank runs over somebody
well it doesn't actually run them over
the guy just goes underneath he lies
flat and goes between the treads we sat
there we looked at it there's enough
ground clearance we're like now we just
do it for real we're planning on doing
it with the effects and so we actually
in real life took a stunt man and he lay
down on the ground and the tank drove
over him now in bandon brothers stunt
coordinator was talking about the same
thing and he's like well the abandoned
brothers they actually ran somebody over
the tank for real like really yeah and
so i looked at the footage
and they did indeed run somebody over
for real
so what they did is they dug a hole and
they filled that hole with home like
cubes and you know basically just
chopped up foam and stuff and then put
like a layer of dirt and sod on top the
guy actually laid down on it and they
ran over they took the tank and ran over
him with the tank treads pushing him
down into the foam
and just had to drive over him and then
drive away so he'd come back out of the
phone
and that's like gotta be one of the most
terrifying
scary things to ever do because
if the tank breaks down
while it's on top of you you're dead
all right at least you're trapped maybe
not dead but you'll be in that phone for
a while because the clips online i'm
sure carmichael's cutting to b-roll the
whole time i'm talking about it
but you know what really bugs me about
that shot
is that they cut away so much
that it could have just been simply vfx
and there's nothing cool about it
anymore like they should have seen that
guy fall over scramble and the tank
treads slowly running him over all in
one uncut take we've been like watching
a magic trick
we just saw john wick 2
last week
and that was it was nice to see somebody
doing stunt work and showing the whole
thing like when the dude gets hit by a
car they don't like have the car bump
the guy they cut to the guy in the air
they cut the guy hitting the ground from
like four different angles it's just
smack fly hit all in one shot
so good
anyways
i thought you guys might be interested
in that little factoid and i think that
stunt deserves a lot more appreciation
so
for me to you
a little bit of knowledge go enjoy
[Music]
dear watchers of salmoneco we have these
limited edition corridor digital retro
90s nerf style shirts you guys want one
you must order them very soon this sale
stops
three days from today
so
jump on them now if you think these
shirts are cool if you would like one
help support the channel helps us grow
thank you so much oh
the link in the description
maybe even on the screen who knows what
kind of tech youtube can do these days
we'll find out when we upload this video
anyways corridor digital.com store
check them out
today we're writing a john wick nerf
video because the new movie just came
out and it's so much better than the
first one we're gonna come up with some
of the craziest action scenes and
sequences that we can inspired by the
movie and recreate them with nerf guns
no no no no because it's the only pistol
one that can use that uses like the
magazines well and you can do all the
reloading tricks with this one because
it's super easy to reload
step out from the shadows into that area
and all we're just going to see in the
background is just like a little
or wait wait
if i was gonna do a shot where you come
into a room and you shoot shoot shoot
you go empty and you flip the mag and
then
you keep shooting like in just in one
flawless motion
it's a lot harder to get my hair
straight than i thought it's not quite
working red is the perfect john wick
doppelganger and obviously counter reads
the best john wick on the planet
i will not surpass either of them
whoa is that john wick
but this that's this this whole video is
just
what is the craziest reloading
like
i'm like no
and i like i grab you and i try and like
look
and then and then i have to go like this
like
throw them at somebody with your gun
oh out of ammo
and then
we're like wrestling
we're like we're like like we're like
locked in like confidently
you're out of ammo and you start
reloading the guy comes around the
corner so you pop the gun here draw your
pistol and you're like dude
yeah yeah while you're yeah
grab
disarm elbow oh wow you do a lot of [ __ ]
and shoot on one
[Music]
or the whole like oh yeah i mean also
from the movies straight up
and it's like
oh [ __ ] out of ammo and
holding the guy drop the dart in
there jam the dart in the air
and then you just go
and like knock it in harder because dude
he's like sitting there like it's like
you don't [ __ ] do it then he gets
like send on the cell phone and john
like shoots in the head of course and
then it cuts to like the whole like you
see the number going out to everybody
and then he's like [ __ ] and you just
know that a bunch of assassins i tend to
kill one action
hey that was that was like
that's like 70
let's get to like 90 before move on
bad news
our nerf shirts are almost out of sale
so if you want one for yourself check
out our store corridor digital.com store
and snag one for yourself these were
designed by the awesome designer jason
cryer he's a really cool dude and he's
really good at designs so if you like
his work check him out on google.com
google.com
anyone do you see my site on google.com
you just go to google.com and type my
name in that's wishing sound like
[Music]
for sake first try
[Music]
here here's my first actual actual first
try
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]